weil das klar also die diese news die
wir plötzlich um die ecke kam das
demnächst möglicherweise auf deutschen
eisenbahnschienen im deutschen
schienennetz kohle züge vorfahrt vor
personenzügen haben werden wir was im
detail jetzt nicht so klar weil ich habe
es nicht bis zum letzten satz die dazu
gehörigen papiere gelesen habe aber es
war klar dass eine behörde die eine
krise zu managen nach prioritäten setzen
muss und dass die priorität darin
besteht dass die volkswirtschaft am
laufen gehalten wird dass strom fließt
und das die menschen schlicht und
einfach durchkommen durch den winter was
heißt das denn konkret wie wird das
aussehen wir stehen irgendwann da an der
haltestelle und dann muss man auch ein
bisschen haben wir mal die sache
nüchtern betrachten momentan ist die
situation so dass wir nicht akut sofort
irgendwo mangelerscheinungen haben wir
haben ja einen preis problem das ist
welche noch zu besprechen wo wir
wirtschaftliche schwierigkeiten sehen
und auch schon haben die dazu führen
dass existenzen gefährdet sind und dass
wir möglicherweise wieder unternehmen
die wir mühsam auch im aufbau ist
geschaffen haben und haben entstehen
sehen wieder verlieren sondern das ist
ein prozess der sicherlich auch
durchwachsen wird hängt auch von den
lieferkonditionen ab was zum beispiel
gas anbelangt aber eben auch kohle die
wir alternativ einsetzen müssen um
wieder reaktivierten kraftwerken oder
noch laufenden gott sei dank noch
laufenden kraftwerken und neben zufolge
ist das erste mal zu sichern bevor alles
andere stattfindet das ist
nachvollziehbar das ist normales
krisen-management der verkehrsminister
bundesverkehrsminister wissen hat das
bestätigt und sagte wenn es dazu kommen
sollte dass wir die priorisierung der
kohletransporte aktivieren müssen dann
kann es passieren dass am ende auch am
personenzug warten muss denn die
versorgung der kraftwerke vorrangig das
ist so wenn kein strom da ist dann sind
die krankenhäuser nicht funktionsfähig
dann müssen operationen nicht nur
verschoben werden sondern vielleicht
unterbrochen werden dann ist die gesamte
infrastruktur die ja auch im sinne von
telekommunikation an elektrifizierung
gehängt ist gefährdet und funktioniert
nichts mehr in dieser gesellschaft wir
haben wir das buch blackout gelesen hat
der weiß was für eine katastrophe da
sind sie sind physiker sowie das ist
also das wäre der supergau und alles
andere ob jemand mal später oder
sozusagen ein zug aussetzen musste und
etwas später irgendwo hinkommt ist
nachrangig gegenüber dem dass wir diesen
super gau erleben und und und was
müssten wir dann auch in ihren augen
bereits sein sozusagen in kauf zu nehmen
also die debatte tobt ja auch längst
nämlich an den anfang der diskussion
da hieß es immer an das ist doch klar
eu-recht priorisiert privatwohnungen
privathaushalte das sind die letzten
denen irgendetwas abgeklemmt wird
plötzlich geht die debatte ganz anders
also menschen sind bereit im zweifel
kältere wohnungen in kauf zu nehmen um
den arbeitsplatz auf der anderen seite
zu helfen und mannschaft das jetzt nicht
in unterschiedlichen schichten sehen wo
es die erste schicht gibt die man
abräumen kann keine industriebetriebe
mehr denn je nächster wo die
öffentlichen bereiche auch die behörden
reduzieren beziehungsweise geschlossen
werden und dann erst die privaten
haushalte es ist alles miteinander
verbunden nichts funktioniert tag für
sich alles muss in gewisser weise
funktionsfähig gehalten werden so dass
wahrscheinlich in allen bereichen
gleichzeitig sukzessive wenn eine mange
lage entsteht auch reagiert werden
musste durch zuteilung durch die
management von mangel das muss man auch
klar sagen und wichtig ist dass die
grundvoraussetzung für eine gesellschaft
da ist dass die infrastruktur
funktioniert und damit nicht ein
absolutes chaos ok zweite interessante
geschichte liegen der sendung rauskam
war auf die frage ob es denn stimmen
würde dass wir im mai und im juli glaube
ich war es so viel gas zu strom gemacht
haben wir noch nie in der geschichte
unseres landes sagt herr müller ja
das begrünen
aber auf der anderen seite hören wir
appelle duscht weniger spart energie wo
immer könnt und wir machen dieses
wertvolle gas zu strom also meine frage
ist haben sie das gefühl dass wir
wirklich mit aller macht alles tun was
geht um strom auf andere art und weise
zu produzieren wo sind die großen
kohletransporte wo ist die ernsthafte
debatte über die laufzeitverlängerung
von drei noch verbliebenen
atomkraftwerken beispielsweise gut die
atomkraftdebatte weil ich ja nicht
reinziehen
weil ich lange genug um unsere
kohlekraftwerke gekämpft habe in
mitteldeutschland aber vor allen dingen
auch in sachsen-anhalt in schkopau ein
modernes kohlekraftwerk was in den 20er
jahren ursprünglich geschliffen werden
sollte zusammen mit dem kohleausstieg wo
es uns gelungen ist das bis mitte der
30er jahre zu erhalten heute sind wir
heilfroh dass wir das haben und ich habe
eine coole kommission wo es hat der
diskussion in den großen runden gegeben
hat immer darauf hingewiesen
energiewende alles gut klimaziele wollen
wir alle erhalten aber in dem moment wo
wir diese vorhandenen strukturen mit
energie erzeugungsarten rausnehmen aus
dem netz
bringen wir das zusätzlich auf dem markt
und gras ist zusätzlich derzeit nur in
russland damals zu haben gewesen und als
es hieß unsere kraftwerke abgerissen
werden waren sofort die entsprechenden
ursprünglichen kraftwerksbetreiber bei
uns und wollten neuer gaskraftwerke
bauen ich habe auf die abhängigkeit
hingewiesen ich habe gesagt jedes
kraftwerk was wir konventionelle oder
akw mäßig vom netz nehmen heißt höhere
abhängigkeit vom russischen gas gibt es
ausreichend zeugen das war ja klar
brauche ich brauche ich diese diskussion
jetzt zu führen weil ich es live erlebt
habe bis hin zum antragsverfahren was
als wir das kraftwerk dann bis 35 retten
konnten wieder zurückgezogen werden
konnte und dieses gas kraftwerk nicht
gebaut wird und andere haben das gemacht
die haben sich von konventionellen bzw
bisher verwendeten energie
erzeugungsarten verabschiedet haben das
durch gas kompensiert und hängen jetzt
natürlich sehr steuer das hat aber das
hat ihnen war klar worauf das
hinauslaufen könnte es war klar dass
jeder jedes element was wir bisher in
energieerzeugung entziehen durch gas als
brücken über die abhängigkeit von
russland natürlich und wo soll das
herkommen wir hatten bei den german
terminals waren nicht da das heißt es
ging nur über die pipeline south stream
2 war im bau es war sozusagen der
kapazitäts verdopplung ja für jeden
optisch sichtbar es kann noch keiner
sagen aus wien ich kein journalist kann
sagen das war nicht allen offenkundig
und zwar immer auch unter dem
gesichtspunkt wir müssen die klimaziele
erreichen und es geht darum auch die
welt zu retten wofür ich immer zu haben
bin ich nicht
ist daran kann ich mich auch noch
erinnern es gab interviews von und mit
reiner haseloff in denen er klar gesagt
hat er spricht sich für die beibehaltung
der kohleenergie aus weil wir uns nicht
zu abhängig von wladimir putin machen
dürfen das stimmt das habe ich heute
auch noch mal nachgelesen was haben sie
zum beispiel gesagt in einem interview
von 2009/10 meine ich man muss
allerdings dazu sagen dass diese politik
dieses war man vor einer abhängigkeit
von russland nicht besonders konsistent
war also auch nicht die von reiner
haseloff sie haben sich herr haseloff
gemeinsam mit allen anderen
ministerpräsidenten hier beispielsweise
immer dafür eingesetzt dass nord stream
2 gebaut wird so auch da war ja klar
dass uns diese pipeline in eine größere
abhängigkeit von russland bringen kann
also ich hatte eher den eindruck dass
sie dieses argument wir dürfen uns nicht
zu abhängigkeit abhängig machen von
russland auch benutzt haben dafür länger
bei der kohleenergie zusätzliche für
sachsen-anhalt vision ist es müssen wir
noch mal wirklich den deckel auf den
topf bringen
wir haben uns zur einhaltung der
klimaziele verpflichtet das heißt dass
im großen maßstab alles an fossilen
brennstoffen braucht muss aus der
energieerzeugung und das heißt
wasserstoff ist nicht da speicher sind
nicht da weltweit übrigens nicht dass
wir auf brückentechnologie gas umstellen
müssen alleine die klimaziele die sich
die jetzige bundesregierung im jetzigen
koalitionsvertrag gestellt hat diese
klimaziele sind nur zu erreichen wenn
einer größenordnung von 40 bis 50
zusätzlichen gaskraftwerken bord
kompensiert wird und wo soll denn das
gas herkommt jetzt bauen wir mühsam lng
terminals es war klar dass es nur
pipeline gas geben kann und dass dieses
nur aus russland kommt mir das sozusagen
wegdrückt da ist einfach historisch
nicht dabei gewesen da muss ich mal
sagen weil es klar war dass dieses gas
nicht irgendwo rum liegt und das ist
insgesamt auch bezahlbar sein muss
momentan haben wir die substitution
prozesse zu laufen die gaspreise haben
sie vor 3458 und die wirtschaft steht
schon in teilen das sehen auch die
konsequenz wäre dass wir über viele
viele jahre insgesamt von gas abhängig
sind aber natürlich jetzt erstmal auch
versuchen wollte vom russischen geltung
und zu importieren euro und das ist auch
in der industriepolitik waren auch
deutlich erkennbaren
ehrlichkeit gebietet es in der tat so
sagen dass wir die eingetretene
situation wir alle verantwortlich sind
jeder von uns auf die wir hier sitzen
zumindest jeder partei gestimmt hat in
der vergangenheit die für die
energiewende und die einhaltung der
klimaziele eingetreten ist denn was
geschehen ist war ganz offensichtlich
weg von anderen fossilen energieträgern
weg von nuklear weg von kohle und dann
blieb das und wer sind die größten
gasproduzenten der erde der iran china
katar russland so das war die auswahl
und hätte man noch sagen können da
kaufen ist auch schmutziges fracking
gast von den amerikanern oder kanadier
und jetzt könnt ihr euch mal vor der
letzten bundestagswahl hätte sich ein
deutscher politiker eine politikerin hin
gestellten hätte gesagt also das mit der
abhängigkeit von russland ist schlecht
wir kaufen jetzt beim iran oder bei cata
lauter und es war sozusagen der
demokratie und wir kaufen der schmutzige
fracking gas von den amerikanern wir
haben uns abhängig gemacht von
gasthermen uns abhängig gemacht von
einer bestimmten infrastruktur war die
deutsche wirtschaft noch nicht bereit
war entschied er - zu bauen insofern
finde ich ist ein gebot der ehrlichkeit
zu sagen verantwortlich sind wir alle
und es ist nicht redlich immer mit dem
finger auf einzelne zu zeigen die das
ist das tut mir leid da gehe ich nicht
mit dass das ist der der st der
rhetorische kniffe der im moment häufig
benutzt wird das werfe ich ihnen jetzt
nicht vorher von fritsch überhaupt nicht
aber ich hatte das jüngste in der
sendung hier auch mit sigmar gabriel der
sagt wir haben da große fehler gemacht
und dann kommt die einschränkung
hinterher die entscheidende
einschränkung die haben wir alle gemacht
kann aber rastet dritten ausstieg aus
der atomenergie mit dem habe ich nichts
zu tun je nach hat hat es mit getragen
und mit entscheiden jeder der vertretung
angetreten ist wusste dass er abhängig
werden vom gas und von einer bestimmten
infrastruktur also der atomausstieg der
ist gesellschaftlich so konsensfähig
dank breiter gemacht gewesen dass
letztendlich der weg dafür ist hat die
grüne potter extra gegründet wurden der
weg projiziert war in dem moment an dem
man selbst ihre gesehen wie das gemacht
hat das richtig seine partei das ist das
ist richtig aber letztendlich der
ausstieg war vorher schon beschlossen
die neuen den zeitlichen ablauf war mal
beschlossen dann ist er wieder deutlich
zurückgenommen worden aber nicht
zurückgenommen worden um es weitere
laufen zu lassen sondern um die
zeitachse zu verschieben aber der
atomausstieg war immer konsens über alle
parteien in dieser gesellschaft ich
finde dass eröffnung einer abfrage so
dass wenn sie heute die bevölkerung ab
anfragen würden zwar jetzt über die
laufzeitverlängerung der drei akw es
vielleicht ein positives votum erzeugt
bei wäre aber grundsätzlich eine
revitalisierung der atomindustrie nicht
mehrheitsfähig sind die regler schon
ganz schön von mindestens ein oder zwei
generationen und neue technologien opfer
aber hängen direkt sagen doch die
umfragen etwas ganz anderes die mehrheit
der deutschen will will atomenergie
haben ja ich finde man es geht um genau
ein sieg muss her unterscheidet zwischen
laufzeitverlängerung und zwischen dem
generell wieder an der reihe
das ist ein riesiger unterschied
und letzteres ist nur möglich wenn die
generationswechsel stattgefunden hat und
wenn auch neue technologien mit völlig
neuen auch kleineren reaktoren
möglicherweise auf den markt kommen das
dauert aber noch jahrzehnte wir sind
erstmal jetzt unterwegs kann
brückentechnologie mindestens bis 2050
über gas sichern müssen und da das gas
von den russen substituiert werden muss
brauchen wir uns von woanders her und
das wird auf dauer teurer sein und das
wird ein camp der gesellschaft damit
müssen wir uns abfinden
ich glaube nur dass mit der
verantwortung ist ein bisschen einfach
denn wir haben
leiter des staates wir haben eine
kanzlerin gehabt ministerpräsidenten und
so die natürlich ein angaben diplomaten
wir haben generale ein anderes wissen
haben als der durchschnittliche oder so
und wir können dann können diejenigen
die in verantwortung sind nicht sagen
sorry ihr seid alle dabei habe der cdu
der spd gewählt oder so weil man dann
erwarte ich natürlich schon und nichts
ist kräftiger als das argument und
angela merkel hat ja in ihrem ersten
öffentlichen
reden wieder gesagt sie hat putin so
verstanden uns die demokratie verachtet
er hätte sie es mal gesagt hätte sie das
mal gesagt und uns ihr wissen mal
mitgeteilt und dass man dann die
diversifiziert dann noch sagt wir können
jetzt nicht von einem sauberen land gas
beziehen wir müssen versuchen breiter zu
werden und die erklärung die die herr
habe jetzt zum beispiel gemacht man
merkt dass sie mir auch anders als auch
nicht glück in katar jetzt sein gas zu
kaufen da glauben wir werden nie ganz
von dem gas runter zu kommen aber die
erhöhung von 30 prozent auf über 50%
senat abhängig gemacht und da hat
natürlich in der botschaft in moskau
sonst irgendwo ambiente ich weiß nicht
wo die die alarmglocken
zwar machen ja politisch aber wir waren
davor man kann auch diese argumente
bringen ich glaube man muss wenn die
politik die argumente nicht bringt und
dann sagen ja ihr bevölkerung hätte uns
ja warnen müssen und warum seid ihr uns
gefolgt was hören sie frau hin ich wenn
sie durchs land reisen wie groß ist die
angst die angst vor dieser gas mangel
lage dieser berühmt-berüchtigten leuna
ist ein stichwort die gasanlage die
frage sind die leute in der lage das zu
bezahlen wie groß ist möglicherweise
auch der frust darüber dass man das
nicht ähnlich macht wie es andere länder
auch tun ich meine man könnte ja über
eine über gewinn steuer vielleicht so
etwas finanzieren wir haben uns dazu
entschieden jetzt den leuten noch mal
zusätzlich vierköpfiger haushalt im
schnitt zu sagen 5 600 euro mehr pro
jahr wird es für dich definitiv werden
das ist eine ganz schwierige situation
vor allem für sachsen anhalt muss man
sagen weil sie haben das eben schon
erwähnt sachsen anhalt eine starke
chemieindustrie hat und die
chemieindustrie ist gerade in schweren
situationen wahrscheinlich weil sie
einen enorm hohen energieverbrauch hat
also ich habe heute gelesen dass es
einen düngemittelhersteller gibt in
sachsen-anhalt er braucht so viel
energie wie bremen und das saarland
zusammen und meiner heimatstadt
wittenberg gas wird also nicht nur
größer ist dass wir die frage des ok und
gas wird dann nicht nur gebraucht als
energieträger sondern auch als rohstoff
für die produktion das kommt noch dazu
das heißt wir haben ein land das ohnehin
nicht über allzu viele industrien
verfügt weil das wissen wir alle damit
will ich jetzt nicht langweilen aber die
nachwendezeit war auch eine zeit der die
industrialisierung in ostdeutschland so
viele mit ihnen droht ein
produktionsstopp ja ist einer der
grössten düngemittelherstellern
deutschen dozierende ja nicht und
und jetzt muss entschieden werden ob im
oktober überhaupt wieder hochgefahren
wird weil die jeden monat 70 bis 90
millionen - machen also um 70 bis 90
millionen - machen
bei den jetzigen preisen
900 arbeitsplätze wie viel sind das rund
1000 man alles zusammenrechnet
dienstleister und da hängen auch noch
andere betriebe daran die bis nach einer
hinreichend die den harnstoff benötigen
für für die produktion das heißt hier
geht es nicht darum das gas hier
eingesetzt wird als energieträger wir
haben ja kohle und wind sondern das ist
die stoffliche verwertung dass ich am
gas geht in das produkt in den
kunststoff in diese mittel für die
landwirtschaft und so weiter da findet
noch mal fragen die in die politische
frage lacht er über gewinnen steuer
würde warum die spanier haben es heute
gemacht
die finanzieren damit verschiedenste
dinge über gewinn steuer zum beispiel
den öpnv warum machen wir das nicht so
wir brauchen mechanismen um das
sozusagen zu finanzieren und wir müssen
auch abgriffe organisieren die aber bis
hin auch in die kontrolle der märkte
hinein geht das heißt was an der
strombörse in leipzig passiert dass der
teuerste einspeisung soll sozusagen den
preis bestimmt während andere günstigere
erzeugungsarten bis hin zum erneuerbaren
strom entsprechend jetzt windfall
profits einfahren diese ganze systematik
einschließlich kartellrechtlicher
kontrollen und preiskontrollen muss
vielseitig ergreifen wir brauchen aber
eben auch den zugriff auf diese been for
profit das heißt diejenigen die jetzt
sich wirklich mal etwas über gerd dumm
und dämlich verdienen ja so und in die
frage ist welches instrument feldherrn
lindner und der bundesregierung ein um
das wirklich effektiv zu machen werden
sie viele übergewichtige bei uns viele
konzerne total zb die raffinerien neuner
hat ihren standort in paris das heißt
und basf ist ein globaler konzern wenn
er erst mal vermessen scheint ausdenke
mit einem roman wir brauchen also dinge
dass wir auch dran kommen auch
steuerrechtlich ankommen wo werden die
steuern veranlagt wo wird der gewinn
verbucht und wo kann man ihn abgreifen
und das ist eine frage der steuertechnik
und da brauchen wir auf jeden fall ideen
meiner hand ist im bundesrat sofort hoch
wenn es darum geht dieses geld
abzugreifen und asyl erst einmal
gewinnen steuer machen die so genannten
begriff überlegen ob wir brauchen wir
brauchen ein angriff dessen bei
denjenigen die derzeit da von einem
profi ziehen so und das muss umverteilt
werden nicht nur die sozialen bereiche
hinein das klar das ist logisch aber
wenn wir zum beispiel das düngemittel
werk piesteritz verlieren würden das ist
der grösste
mitteleuropäische düngemittelproduzent
den es gibt für die eigene
landwirtschaft strategisch wichtig und
wir führen stattdessen weil die jetzt
vom markt sind die düngemittel von iran
werfen von arabischen staaten von
russland weil das haus genommen ist aus
der sanktionen war ständig da der welt
versorgung in ernährungsfragen auch
dient gehen das heißt die die deutschen
fliegen hier raus also unsere werke
werden putin profit macht und von den
hohen düngemittelpreise noch zusätzlich
jetzt verdient und da müssen wir rein
wenn wir den wirklich treffen wollen
müssen wir ständig nachjustieren
um wirklich wirkung zu entfalten punkte
also das ist er wie sehr schnell gemacht
und irgendwann den kriegen das ganze ins
rutschen weil auf der einen seite
diejenigen die sozusagen als sgb 2
leistungserbringung für hartz iv
empfänger genannt die bekommen die
warmmiete vom staat aber die ihnen die
im unteren drittel der lohnskala laufen
die rutschen jetzt wunder entkommen die
grundsicherung und wir brauchen jetzt
auch mit dem kanzler besprochen eine
wohngeldreform generell länder leistungs
reform wo wir genau auch diese
arbeitende bevölkerung die jetzt
wirklich hart getroffen ist schon jetzt
getroffen ist unbedingt anfangen es wird
ein großer umverteilungs prozess sein
der dann aber auch reicht bis in die
wirtschaft hinein wenn wir nicht
strategische dinge verlieren wollen und
an der stelle uns wieder abhängig machen
von ländern wofür wir uns vorstellten
lassen mussten schlicht und einfach weil
das in den letzten jahrzehnten basiert
ist wir sind ein rohstoffarmes land wir
haben nun die menschen wir haben nur den
kopf denken und zu arbeiten
den rest holen wir von außen und jetzt
müssen wir sehen wie wir das
diversifizieren aber es ist eben nicht
beliebig am markt greifbar wer diese
mengen substituieren will läuft derzeit
ins leere freilich wird das ihrer
meinung nach dazu führen
das dass es unruhig wird dass wir wieder
proteste sehen werden dass wir wirklich
montagsdemos sehen werden dass all diese
dinge wieder passieren es gibt ja
genügend politiker die das befürchten da
muss ich sagen ich habe eigentlich von
märz an erwartet dass es demonstrationen
geben wird auch in ostdeutschland denn
da haben wir sozusagen eine
infrastruktur schon die da es ist haben
einfach sehr viele leute demonstriert in
den zurückliegenden jahren in
ostdeutschland bei p&g da haben wir das
gesehen bei den crooner demonstration
und wenn einmal so ein netz da ist dann
lassen sich normalerweise auch schneller
wieder leute mobilisieren das ist
bislang bis jetzt nicht passiv
schauerlicher weise
das haben die linken aufgerufen einen
heißen herbst zu organisieren dann sind
die rechten und die linken auf der
gleichen straße zum gleichen thema und
das erinnert mich an verschiedenen
punkten an die deutsche geschichte wo
ich sage wenn wir da nicht als
demokraten gegen halten wie ein gutes
auf den heißen
haben
potenzial überlassen das ist ja eine
ganz relevante eigenes protestpotenzial
aktiv momentan ist das sehr stark auf
die russische komponente konzentriert
nicola kiste ist abgeräumt weil momentan
ist zwar da ist aber nicht verspürt wird
und die linke wird eine völlig andere
strategie fahren die liegen bundesweit
bei 5 prozent bei denen geht es beim die
überlebensfrage die instrumentalisieren
das thema knackig und hat nicht umsonst
ramelow wies das als ministerpräsident
spielen die mit dem feuer und die
stabilisieren dieses diese freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung wie wir das
schon mal in der deutschen geschichte
erlebt haben dass rechts und links
dieses zerrbild der erste republik ist
daran gescheitert und jetzt wird dort zu
sagen ich finde ich den teufel an die
wand malen noch haben wir das im griff
deswegen sind wir als politiker jetzt
gut beraten bei all den möglichkeiten
die wir jetzt haben einschließlich auch
der öffentlichen meinungsbildung gut
beraten zusammen zu stehen weil wir
ostdeutschen die geschichte lernen
sollten und deswegen denke ich möchte zu
ihr stehen jene die den heißen herbst
organisieren putins spiel spielen er
kalkuliert ganz genau darauf dass wir
uns zeigen dass wir uns da setzen wir
unseren gesellschaften auf kaum ein land
schaut er auf kaum ein land kommt es so
an genau wie auch nutzen das historiker
noch mal sagen also die
die erste republik hat sich zerlegt aber
das war natürlich viel extremere
rahmenbedingungen einem krieg sind
schließlich kann man lieber
wäre den einiges interessante jahr das
in den ende der 20er jahre die extreme
linke und rechte anwuchs und sie haben
es eben erwähnt die linke der letzten
bundestagswahl das figur und die wahl
von herrn ramelow kann man sich angucken
also
aber hier muss ich einmal skeptisch
nachfragen ich hatte jetzt irgendwie den
eindruck dass sie sozusagen die
demokratie scheitern sehen wenn menschen
auf die straße gehen und demonstrieren
konsum aber erleben wir nicht sozusagen
die vitalität einer demokratie wenn
leute auf die straße gehen also warum
sollte das eine katastrophe sein wenn
die linke demonstration organisiert
sorgen das demonstrationsrecht was wir
auch zu verwendende sehr stark in
anspruch genommen haben um unsere
systeme damals zur demokratie zu führen
das darf nicht angetastet werden aber
wir sind jetzt in einer krise die wir
nicht national erzeugt haben sondern die
durch einen krieg außerhalb deutschlands
und der europäischen union erzeugt wurde
und wo wir schlicht und einfach die
kollateralschäden bei uns in einer
gesellschaft durch solidarität der
gesamten gesellschaft und der mehrheit
der politisch verantwortlichen
parteiübergreifend dort letztendlich
überzeugt haben und die effekte jetzt
gemeinsam auch prüfen müssen und das ist
ein völlig anderer sachzusammenhang als
dass ein demonstrationsrecht wenn es
darum geht ob in der maske so rum oder
warum getragen werden muss in anspruch
genommen wird hier geht es darum dass
der putin nur zu sagen daran gehindert
wird die weltordnung komplett zu feiern